[Musique]
Mandela un symbole contre l'apartaille
de documentaire réalisé par François
Xavier destor 10 ans après sa
disparition que dire aujourd'hui de
l'héritage laissé par celui qui incarna
pendant longtemps et bien au-delà de
l'Afrique du Sud des valeurs de paix et
de réconciliation nous allons en
débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débadoc avec
vous pour commencer Marianne Séverin
bienvenue à vous vous êtes chercheur
associé au laboratoire de recherche Les
Afriques dans le monde Science Po
Bordeaux spécialiste de l'Afrique du Sud
et vous avez entre autres collaboré à ce
livre collectif Afrique du Sud 20 ans de
démocratie contrastée un ouvrage publié
chez l'armatan Francis CAPTIN est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
ancien rédacteur en chef de jeuneafrique
vous avez été porte-parole du Haut
Commissariat des Nations Unies pour les
réfugiés et vous êtes aujourd'hui maître
de conférence à sciencep Paris
vous étiez en Afrique du Sud juste avant
l'élection qui a vu Mandela être le
premier président noir en Afrique du Sud
vous étiez en Afrique du Sud entre
1993 et
1994 on en reparlera bien sûr dans un
tout petit moment pierreasky est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste auteur vos éditau consacrés
à la politique internationale sont à
écouter chaque matin dans la matinale de
nos confrères de France Inter vous êtes
par ailleurs le président de reporter
sans frontières et vous étiez vous en
Afrique du Sud entre
1976 et 1980 pour le compte de l'Agence
France press on va y revenir dans un
instant vous avez par ailleurs contribué
au tout dernier numéro de la revue
légende qui est entièrement consacrée à
Mandela je montre cette revue elle est
magnifique c'est ériic fotorino l'ancien
directeur du monde qui dirige cette
revue je la conseille à tous et ce tout
dernier numéro est consacré justement à
Nelson Mandela 1976 c'est le moment où
vous arrivez donc en Afrique du Sud vous
êtes passé à Johannesbourg et là vous
assistez d'emblé eu au massacre de de
Seto oui le 16 juin 76 c'est le
soulèvement des jeunes de Seto et c'est
un bansang parce que la la police tire
et c'est là que je prends aussi
conscience de l'importance de Mandela
parce que euh les les parents de ces
jeunes se sont réunis euh pour essayer
de calmer le jeu et le lendemain matin
il y avait un face- àface entre les
jeunes et la police et et un groupe
d'adultes arrive essae de parlementer
ils se font balayer par les policiers
qui ne veulent rien entendre et une
femme sort de ce groupe s'adresse au
policiers leur dit vous savez qui je
suis je suis la femme de Nelson Mandela
c'était Winnie Mandela donc on a vu par
la suite effectivement sortie la sortie
de prison de Mandela mais qui qui était
l'incarnation de de cette volonté de
garder le nom de Mandela vivant parce
que Mandela était déjà en prison depuis
des années il son nom était interdit sa
son image était interdite dans la presse
sud-africaine et elle se battait pour
que le nom de Mandela reste fort on va
revoir un premier extrait du film après
cette anecdote euh et se vécu hein en en
1976 de votre côté pieraski il concerne
justquement ce qui l'Afrique du Sud dans
les années
60 Afrique du Sud prospère dans les
années 60 et renvoie l'image d'un
paradis blanc les grandes puissances se
partagent ses richesses naturelles ses
diamants et son or et soutiennent un
régime devenu un allié de poids face au
bloc soviétiqu au nom de la lutte contre
le péril communiste le monde occidental
se détourne du sort de
Mandela c'est donc au nom de de la lutte
antiommuniste que la plupart des
puissances occidentales soutiendront
régime de la par c'est peut-être bon de
le rappeler avant de avant toute chose
exactement euh on est dans une période
de guerre froide
euh et
malheureusement
laanc qui est le parti Nelson Mandela
est considéré comme un un parti
communiste et et on on parle de
terrorisme euh et c'est peut-être un une
explication un peu simpliste puisque en
fait laanc collabore et très proche du
Parti communiste qui avait déjà été
interdit en
1950 et bénéficier en fait du soutien de
l'exurss et notamment lorsqu'il fallait
acheter des armes et euh former les
cadres militaires de la branche armée
euh de de laanc donc il n'est pas
étonnant en fait que euh finalement les
pays dit occidentaux se soi alliés au
régime d'apparteille contre le contre
l'ex URSS c'est une période où la NC est
complètement inaudible où Nelson Mandela
n'apparaît nulle part oui parce que on
était alors dans un monde maniquin il y
a les bons les mauvais selon l'endroit
où on se place et et la NC était
vraiment le diable pour certains pays
comme les États-Unis et même en France
tout le monde ne soutenait pas la NC il
y avait le Parti communiste il y avait
le mouvement ATI à partède il y avait un
mouvement qui appar en France il y avait
les syndicats comme la CGT qui soutenit
sinon les autres regardaient parce que
il y avait selon l'Occident un péril
communistes or Mandela était proche de
ces pays-là mais il a eu également
d'autres soutien en Afrique notamment
des pays progressistes ce qu'on appelait
pays progress l'Algérie euh tous ces
pays la Tanzanie avait soutenu euh armé
entraîné et même donneré de l'argent à
la NC alors pierre has qui euh euh autre
épisode hein de de votre bout de
carrière passé en Afrique du Sud c'est
1977 parce que vous ferez partie du
cercle restreint convoqué par le
gouvernement sud-africain à l'époque
pour aller rendre visite à Nelson
Mandela et aller visiter cette fameuse
prison de de Roben Iceland où il était
interné voà c'est c'est c'est la seule
visite de journalistes qui a été
organisé par les autorités
sud-africaines qui était destiné à
répondre à un rapport de l'ONU qui
parlait de mauvais traitement et donc on
nous a fait venir il y avait toute la
presse sud-africaine et les agents de
presse internationale moi j'étais donc à
l'agence France- presse et et et les
règles du jeu étaient très strictes
interdiction de parler aux prisonniers
donc on les voyait mais on ne pouvait
pas leur parler et deuxièmement nos
articles étaient soumis à la censure
mais malgré tout nous avons estimé que
ne serait-ce que de voir l'état dans
lequel il vivait dans cette prison qui
est une île au large de de du Cap valait
le coup et et on est rentré dans la
cellule deandéa donc où il y avait la la
photo de Winnie de de sa
femme il y avait quelques livres c'était
extrêmement rudimentaire mais malgré
tout il avait un lit ce qui n'était pas
le cas de beaucoup de prisonniers et
puis ensuite on l'a vu et il était en
train de jardiner et et là il y a une
photo très célèbre qui qui est réapparue
qui est apparue beaucoup plus tard où où
Mandela fait la gueule il est il a un
bob sur la tête il est là avec sa bêche
et il fait une tête de quelqu'un qui est
pas content et en fait je lui ai demandé
quand je l'ai rencontré des années après
quand il a été libéré donc 20 ans après
je lui ai demandé s'il se souvenait de
cette visite et il m'a dit et comment je
m'en souviens j'étais furieux parce
qu'on nous mettait en pâure devant des
journalistes on nous prenait en photo
sans nous demander notre accord et donc
on comprend tout d'un coup cette photo
où il est là avec sa sa son bob sur la
tête à faire la tête et sa colère d'être
exhibé sans pouvoir s'exprimer
évidemment mais voilà c'était vous avez
fait partie de ces privilégiés qu'on pu
le voir ouis à cette époque précise hein
ce qui était pas le cas évidemment de du
reste de la planète jusqu'à tel point
que dans les années 80 on a bâti hein ce
myth c'est ce que nous raconte le film
que nous avons vu ensemble et on va voir
un deuxième extrait du
documentaire libéré Nelson Mandela ce
slogan qui va devenir le refrain de
toute une génération antiraciste aux
quatre coins du globe émerge au début
des années
80 main dans la main avec l'ANC le
mouvement antiapartiide engage peu à peu
toutes les forces de la société civile
dans cette croisade
internationale son but libérer Mandela
et l'Afrique du Sud du jou de la
politique
d'aparted deux objectifs qui se
confondent en une seule image celle du
visage d'un inconnu qui devient en
quelques années le prisonnier politique
le plus célèbre du monde c'est un
inconnu qui devient le prisonnier
politique le plus célèbre au monde
est-ce qu'il caionnait bel et bien tout
cela depuis sa sa prison Mandela euh
pour ce qu'on en sait alors je n'en sais
rien mais par
contre il faut parce qu'on parle
toujours Nelson Mandela mais il faut pas
oublier les gens autour oui et c'est eux
qui tiraent les ficelles les gens autour
là visiblement voilà dans la prison et à
l'étranger parce qu'on a l'ANC en
prison avec Nelson Mandela et on a l'ANC
en exil donc ce qu'on app en
GrandeBretagne en Grande-Bretagne et
également en en Afrique
exactement et en fait c'est c'est c'est
toute une collaboration il était très au
courant parce que les informations
passai j'ai eu l'occasion de
d'interviewer quelques vétérans de laanc
quand j'ai fait mon terrain en Afrique
du Sud et je comprenait pas bien comment
les informations filtrraéent et ils
m'ont expliqué qu'il voilà qu'il y avait
toujours moyen de faire passer les les
les informations à l'intérieur même de
la prison et à l'extérieur et il y avait
une sorte de
collaboration en fait la mission en exil
et et et l'ANC àob éétait pas séparé
était pas isolé puis il faut aussi se
rappeler que bah en 76 les jeunes qui
qui qui qui se sont révoltés contre le
pouvoir en place ce sont des gens aussi
qui ont adopté l'idéologie du mouvement
de la conscience noire donc ces jeunes
là sont arrivés en prison et finalement
on ont pu
fournir Nelson Mandela en information
puce que il est en prison il sait pas ce
qui se passe en Afrique du Sud à
l'intérieur et vous avez une génération
donc cette génération du mouvement de la
conscience noire qui arrive en prison et
qui lui fournit des informations et
c'est comme ça que la lutte continue
donc vous avait une autre vague qui qui
de jeunes politiques de jeunes engagés
contre la la NC contre pardon contre le
régime d'apar qui rentre en prison ou
qui part en exil et en fait c'est très
important ce que dit Marien c'est que en
76 quand il y a le réveil de la société
noire parce que c'est vraiment après la
période de glaciation qui a suivi
l'interdiction de la NC l'emprisonnement
des leaders et cetera il y a une période
pendant laquelle le régime pense qu'il
contrôle bien le pays 76 ça se réveille
ça n'est pas la NC qui est à la manœuvre
c'est la conscience noire la conscience
noire c'est un jeune leader qui
s'appelle Steve qui sera tué par
la police au cours d'un interrogatoire
et et et et les jeunes ne n'adhèrent pas
immédiatement à la NC la NC redeviendra
par la suite le principal mouvement et
effectivement la prison est le lieu
d'échange les autorités savaient ça et
donc avaient isolé tout le groupe des
des des leaders principaux donc Mandela
meky et cetera toyivo le le namibien
était séparé des autres prisonniers mais
comme il y avait des prisonniers plus
jeune qui faisait le ménage qui faisait
la cuisine qui transportait des choses
et cetera il se passait des messages et
l'information circulait et Mandela était
parfaitement au courant de ce qui se
passait dans le pays alors il faudra
peut-être la la conjonction de ce ce
mouvement évoqué à l'instant et et la
Chute bien sûr de l'Union soviétique que
pouvoir se débloquer la la situation on
libère Mandela en 1990 c'est bien comme
ça que les choses se passent il y a il y
a un moment précis de l'histoire où les
choses deviennent possibles oui parce
que le mur tombe et que le monde bon
redevient quasiment unipolaire et Nelson
mandala ser est libéré donc le le 11
février
1990 après les choses vont aller vite
mais les symboles de la partè reste moi
la la première par qui est
officiellement officiellement mais les
symboles pour les enlever arrêter en 91
oui en 91 mais les symboles perdure moi
je suis arrivé en
1993 donc il y avait plus officiellement
d'appartè mais les l'aéroport qui
s'appelait à l'époque Yan smuth et il y
avait toujours les symboles les sorties
pour les Noirs les sorties on les
empruntait plus mais ça existait
toujours et le premier hôtel où j'ai
dormis c'était à rustenberg c'est dans
une ville de l'intérieur et ben il y
avait c'était mis white accommodation
only c'està-dire réservé au blanc et la
Bible était en bonne place sur mon ma
table de Chevé dans la chambre en effet
c'est ça j'aimerais ajouter quelque
chose l'autre raisonussi pour laquelle
la part-ête s'est effondrée c'est qu'à
partir du milieu des années 80 il y a
des négociations secrète entre l'ANC en
exil mais également le petit groupe qui
entoure Nelson Mandela et Nelson Mandela
avec le régime en place donc ça ne vient
pas tout d'un coup parce que le mur
tombe c'est en fait alors que nous nous
enfin peut-être pas moi parce que
j'étais trop jeune mais beaucoup étent
manif est
pour pour que ce régime cesse pendant ce
temps-là pendant ces années ce 85
86 vous avez des négociations qui se
passent et qui finalement vont aboutir à
ces fameuses
négociation officielle à partir de 91 et
il faut pas oublier aussi queil y a il y
a vraiment une le pays devient
progressivement ingouvernable au milieu
des années 80 le gouvernement africain
impose l'état d'urgence parce que il y a
une effervescence dans le pays qui est
totale il y avait une une organisation
qui était née qui s'appelait le le UDF
le Front démocratique uni qui était une
sorte de de façade de l'ANC en fait mais
qui regroupé des des milliers
d'associations locales de groupes locaux
dans dans tout le pays et qui avait
véritablement rendu le pays
ingouvernable en 93 lorsque vous étiez
sur place qu'est-ce qui avait été
négocier qu'est-ce qui était déjà acquis
concernant la lutte contre l'apteille de
il était àquis qu'on irait vers les
élections en 94 ça c'était àquis mais il
y avait trois facteurs de risque quand
moi je suis arrivé il y avait l'extrême
droite africanur qui menaçait de de
la pagaille dans le pays il y
avait ce que moi j'appelle l'extrême
droite noire c'était incata freedom
parti c'était le parti du chef
mangosutou boutelli et qui qui lu aussi
faisait des des actions d'éclat et le
dernier facteur de risque cétait la
persistance de quelques bantouan moi
j'ai été affecté dans un ban tousstan
qui s'appelait bofuta Swana c'est dans
le NordOuest le nord-ouest et là-bas ben
il y avait encore l'extrême droite
africanais qui qui faisait la paga et il
y a eu des exécutions il y a eu des
morts d'ailleurs là-bas quand j'étais là
et voilà donc c'est c'est trois facteurs
de risque c'était ça l'extrême droite
africanur l'extrme droite noire et les
bantouan c'était des fur de R et Mandela
allait arriver au pouvoir essayer de de
de régler tous ces problèmeslà là il
devient un point d'équilibre sur la
scène politique juste avant l'élection à
la présidence de 94 tout à fait euh il
devient un point d'équilibre et il est
aidé par euh
un leader politique communiste qui
s'appelait Joe Slovo qui en fait a
négocié un gouvernement d'unité
nationale parce que au départ euh quand
on consulta les leaders de l'ANC était
hors de question qu'il qu'il gouverne
avec des gens de l'ancien de de de de
l'Ancien Régime finalement et c'est Joe
Slovo qui a été considéré comme un
terroriste communiste et voilà ou lui
aussi lui aussi qui en fait a trouvé ce
moyen pour apaiser les choses et c'était
juste après l'assassinat d'un certain
Chris han euh qui aurait pu faire
basculer euh le pays dans le le sang
puisqu'il avait été assassiné par un
membre de l'extrême droite et et Jo
Slovo pour la petite histoire quand même
c'est intéressant c'est un un un juif de
Lituanie à l'origine qui devient
communiste en Afrique du
Sud qui a vécu en exil à lousaka en
Zambie sa femme a été assassinée par un
colis piégé Ros first elle était au
Mozambique elle a été tuée par un colis
qu'elle a ouvert et qui a explosé entre
ses mains et et lui avait été accusé
d'être un colonel du KGB moi je me
souviens de l'avoir interviewé en Zambie
à l'époque et et il m'avait dit parce
que le Figaro venait de l'accuser d'être
un colonel du KGB Le Figaro français et
il avait dit depuis le temps qu'on me
dit que je suis colonel j'ai même pas
droit à une promotion et et voilà il
avait beaucoup d'humour et il a joué un
rôle déterminant pendant la transition
dernier extrait du du
film pour l'arrivée hein de Mandela à la
présidence de l'Afrique du
Sud a séduit dans les années 90 en nous
faisant croire que les choses
changeraient rapidement il a mis la
puissance de son image au service d'un
projet de réconciliation nationale à
travers des gestes symboliques très
forts comme lors de la Coupe du monde de
rugby en 1995 quand il a porté le
maillot de l'équipe
nationale tout cela représentait
l'Afrique du Sud dont il
rêvait il est donc élu président de
l'Afrique du Sud en en
1994 et là on a le sentiment que le
chantier est énorme j'ai vu dans une
récente interview que vous avez accordé
à l'bdomadaire téérama que les caisses
étaient vides son arrivé au pouvoir dans
quelle situation se trouve-t-il au
moment où il a bel et bien les manettes
du pays bah le pays est à reconstruire
parce que déjà va falloir rassembler le
peuple sud-africain qui est divisé en en
quatre groupes
allez ratio puisque c'était ça hein la
partartate finalement chacun vivait avec
sa communauté et apprenait avec aller à
l'école ou à l'université avec sa sa
communauté donc déjà il faut rassembler
ces personne c'est peut-être symbolique
pour nous mais c'est extrêmement
important et puis oui quand ils sont
arrivés benah finalement les caisses
étaient vide et c'est quelque chose euh
à laquelle lainc ne s'attendait pas du
tout et ça a été en fait une grande
déception quand bah la NC est arrivée au
pouvoir et
le gouvernement d'unité nationale n'a
pas duré très longtemps il a duré 2 ans
parce qu'il y avait pas moyen de
négocier au sein du pouvoir puisque vous
aviez des gens du parti nationaliste qui
avait gouverné l'Afrique du Sud depuis
50 ans qui devait se référer au
président de la République Nelson
MondeLa noir j'imagine que
psychologiquement ça ça pose des des
problèmes donc en 87 laanc se retrouve
quasiment le seul parti à gouverner avec
l'inata alors le chantier est immense le
chantier est immense parce que bon il y
a eu l'artte depuis officiellement
depuis 1948 mais le compromis donc 50
ans d'AAR absolument le compromis qui a
abouti à l'élection de 1980 est très
intéressant d'abord un gouvernement de
transition où tout le monde siégerait
vous aviez donc mandéa en tant que
président un premier vice-président ANC
Frédéric Declerc comme 2uxème
vice-président et vous avez à la
sécurité le
fameux boutéési dont je parlais tout à
l'heure ministre de la Sécurité c'était
lui qui était en charge de ça et la
deuxième chose nous on a reçu
exceptionnellement et instruction je
travaillis pour les Nations Unies
d'aider d'aller dans l'isoloir et
d'aider les gens à voter parce que vous
et moi voter ça pose aucun problème mais
quand vous n'avez jamais voté pour ce
qui était le cas de la communauté noire
et ben il comprenait pas trop c'était un
scrutin un bulletin unique il fallait
les aider et c'était très très très très
émouvant alors sur l'ampleur évidemment
il y a il y a il y a il y a le discours
les promesses et puis une certaine
désillusion d'ailleurs qu'on sent qu'on
perçoit hein dans cet extrait qu'on
qu'on vient de passer sur l'après oui
parce que Mandela s'était fixé comme
mission historique la réconciliation et
et c'est pour ça qu'il a fait qu'un seul
mandat et il a dit moi je suis pas
qualifié pour gérer
l'économie le la reconstruction du pays
et cetera place aux jeunes et en fait
d'une certaine manière c'est là qu' a un
yatus c'est que ses successeurs un n'ont
pas été à la hauteur de de de de la
hauteur à laquelle il avait mis la bar
pour être très honnête en terme à la
fois éthique problème de la corruption
qui a qui a commencé à grandir mais
aussi en terme de de d'habileté
politique Mandela avait un sens de la
politique c'est lui qui a inventé cette
notion de la la la société arc-en-cielle
qui était une manière de dire aux gens
voilà nous sommes différents mais nous
allons vivre ensemble et reconstruire ce
pays ensemble tout ça c'est effrité
progressivement et et et le résultat
c'est ça a été une dégradation de
président en Président on peut-être les
citer hein tabom beeki tabi Tab c'est
intéressant suivi par Jacob Zuma et
ensuite actuellement he r ramaa ce qui
est intéressant c'est que tabom beeki
était le le le fils d'un des compagnons
de de prison de Nelson Mandela Govan
Becky était un des dirigeants de la NC
et et tabo représentait la NC à
l'extérieur il était régulièrement à
Paris moi je le voyais à l'époque où il
était basé à lousaka il avait fait des
études au Royaume-Uni il il cochait
toutes les cases il était fils d'un
grand dirigeant il avait il était d'une
nouvelle génération il avait la
légitimité et cetera et il a été très
décevant et surtout il s'est heurté à
des luttes de Cl clan à l'intérieur de
la NC et Jacob Zuma qui lui est un
ancien chef des services de
renseignement de la NC lui aussi
prisonnier à Robben Island la éincé et
Jacob Zuma a été il faut bien le dire un
désastre pour ce pays puisqu'il a ouvert
grand les Vanes de la corruption et du
népotisme et et il a une responsabilité
énorme dans la désillusion suivante de
l'Afrique du Sud j'ai lu quelque part
que on parler d'une ségrégation raciale
hein dans la période que nous avons
évoqué bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait peut-être parler d'une
ségrégation sociale autrement dit la
population noire n'aurait pas trouvé
toute sa place même aujourd'hui en 2023
dans la société sud-africaine bien sûr
mais alors je voudrais revenir sur
l'intervention concernant l'ex-président
tabo
Miki il y a eu quand même président
entre
1999 et 2009 oui c'est ça oui puisque
quand il a été élu j'étais en j'étais en
Afrique du Sud et en en fait je trouve
que parfois on est un peu sévère avec
lui ou si on compare à ce qui va se
passer par la suite on a tendance à
vouloir
comparer le l'ex-président tabo Meki à
Nelson manda deux personnalités
complètement différente n'appartenant
pas à la même
génération un qui est en prison qui a
peut-être pas notamment Nelson Mandela
la vision globale de qui est le monde
puisquil passe quasiment 30 ans de sa
vie en prison et quelqu'un comme le
l'ex-président toemeki qui a vécu à
l'étranger qui a vu les changements et
qui est un petit peu déconnecté de ce
qui se passe en Afrique du Sud et il a
cette vision très particulière alors
peut-être qu'il nous parle pas à nous
occidentaux de ce qu'on appelle la
Renaissance africaine ce n'est pas
seulement l'Afrique du Sud c'est
ensemble du continent africain et dans
sa politique quand on observe et j'ai
travaillé sur le sujet quand j'ai j'ai
fait ma thèse c'est qu'en fait tabo eki
lui n'est pas dans cet esprit de
gouvernement national et peut-être de
réconciliation et plutôt dans cet esprit
de vouloir donner toute leur place aux
Africains et j' beaup plus volontarise
que Nelson Mandela en matière de
discrimination positive notamment hein
pour exactement faire émerger une classe
moyenne noire sud-africaine
notamment néanmoins aujourd'hui vous
disiez oui il y a encore des
traces parce que 30 ans c'est rien pour
moi enfin dans 30 ans après l'élection
la première élection c'est rien dans
l'histoire de l'Afrique du Sud et tout
pour corriger les choses parce qu'il y
quand même une réforme agraire
discrimination positive avec une
politique le vrai problème de
l' soci ou pasendev ou et surtout aussi
problèm des homess jeais pas comment au
zimbab nous expliquer le problème c'est
c'est l'accès à au logement ouais et ça
récemment moi j'étais au cap et en
repartant vers l'aéroport il y a
toujours C bidonville oui c'est
bidonville qui qui vous arrache cœur
voyez donc le social a été les beaucoup
de noir en tout cas une majorité n'ont
pas le sentiment d'avoir d'en avoir fini
avec la partide enfin dans ça déclin
raison actuelle mais donc il y a un un
souci de social de trouver du boulot aux
gens et de de redistribuer la richesse
parce qu'il y a quand même une minorité
de milliardaires noirs qui qui s'est
installé aux affaires commenc pas
d'ailleurs le président actuel il est il
est il est pas pauvre hein bon donc du
coup c'est ça la question sociale n'a
pas été réglée d'ailleurs c'est ce que
disent les indicateurs que j'ai trouvé
en travaillant ce dossier euh la moitié
de la population sud-africaine vivrait
en dessous du seuil de de pauvreté
un/ers de la population sud-africaine
serait au chômage dont 2 tiers des
jeunes est-ce que la situation n'est pas
tout simplement explosive au vu de ces
indicateur aujourd'hui alors elle est
elle est d'autant plus explosive que il
s'est passé quelque chose c'est que il y
a eu effectivement cette politique de de
de discrimination positive qui a créé
cette classe moyenne noire cette élite
noire qui a été cooptée d'une certaine
manière dans le monde dans le premier
monde qui était exclusivement blanc
précédemment et donc aujourd'hui quand
vous allez dans les beaux quartiers de
Johannesbourg vous avez cette
bourgeoisie noire qui habite là qui
leurs enfants font de de belles études
ils peuvent créer des start-ups et
cetera vous avez ce premier monde là qui
fonctionne en Afrique du Sud et puis
vous avez l'autre moitié du pays qui
attend encore que les promesses de 94
soient tenues en terme de logement
d'accès à l'eau accès à l'éducation
effectivement le cap est un est un bon
exemple parce que toute cette
tout ce qui est derrière la montagne de
la Table vous savez le le cap c'est une
géographie assez particulière c'était là
qui était envoyé les les les métises et
les Noirs à l'époque de la partteille
mais ils sont toujours là et les
quartiers pauvres sont toujours là et
donc effectivement il y a eu cette
barrière sociale qui s'est instaurée et
et et la mobilité et l'état du pays de
l'état de l'économie du pays ne permet
plus aujourd'hui de de continuer ce
volontarisme du début ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est une situation
qui est explosive parce que
l'ANC n'est plus le mouvement des héros
qui ont combattu la parteille de au
sacrifice de leur leader et de leur vie
et cetera c'est aujourd'hui 30 ans d'un
bilan et et donc la jeunesse est est
assez critique à la fois vis-à-vis de la
NC et vis-à-vis de Mandela parce que
vous avez une jeunesse ce qu'on appelle
les Born Free c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont
nés après l'aparthide qui disent mais
Mandela a fait trop de compromis avec
les Blancs il aurait dû faire une
révolution il aurait dû voilà et on on
serait aujourd'hui dans une autre
situation pourtant la NC est
incontournable il reste incontournable
il a toujours été au pouvoir depuis
l'élection à la présidence de Nelson
Mandela et çaà dire que il n'y a pas
d'opposition temps soit
peu crédible à mettre en face de laanc
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas laanc
le problème aujourd'hui en Afrique du
Sud est-ce qu'il faudrait pas tourner
cette page de l'histoire mais pour avoir
qui mais je vous pose la question alors
oui il y a deux oppositions alors il y a
une opposition euh que j'ai je je dirais
extrême voilà une branche extrême
d'extrême droite un peu un peu très
populiste noir populiste noir ouais
populiste noir et que je trouve à mon
avis assez dangereuse et à côté de ça
vous avez une autre
opposition qui représente pas
franchement vraiment qui n'arrivve pas à
représentant représenter l'ensemble de
la population Sud sud-africaine c'est
cette opposition d'ailleurs qui dirige
la province du la province du du du cap
et là on va avoir les
élections l'année prochaine en avril 2
24 ou et la question qui se pose c'est
avec qui l'ANC va devoir gouverner à un
moment donné parce que à priori donc la
question se pose la question se pose
alors juste pour dans le pour on dire
moi je ne crois pas à à la fin de la
part de la NC l'année prochaine la NC en
1994 avait
252 si sur 400 au Parlement je parle pas
des conseil des provinces et et là
actuellement ils ont 232 il y a un
effritement de de l'électorat NC ça
c'est vrai mais je crois pas que le
temps soit venu pour que l' NC n'est
plus la majorité absolue elle a la
majorité absolue aujourd'hui et c'est
vrai qu'il y a ce
mouvement de JIS Malema donc à la gauche
moi je placerai ce moment plutôt à
l'extrême gauche et pas à l'extrême
droite donc et puis il y a l'Alliance
démocratique pas la même chose c'est ça
et puis de l'autre côté il y a
l'Alliance démocratique qui est la
deuxème composante du Parlement
actuellement 86 députés le mot de la
finaski sur la situation politique juste
avant ces élections qui sont qui sont là
à venir
alors je pense qu'effectivement laanc
restera le première force politique la
question c'est est-ce qu'elle aura la
majorité absolue ou est-ce qu'elle sera
obligée de composer et là on rejoint le
choix que que qu'on décrivait
c'est-à-dire est-ce que est-ce qu'ils
vont s'allier sur leur gauche ou sur
leur droite et et et et donc il y a il y
aura une configuration nouvelle en
Afrique du Sud quoi qu'il en soit si
elle n'avait pas la majorité absolue la
NC euh ça serait tout de même un
événement hein au vu de de l'histoire
récente et de l'histoire justement
écrite exactement mand en 94 c'est la
fin de cette émission merci beaucoup
hein vraiment à tous les trois d'y avoir
participé vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag des badooc bien entendu nos
invités seront là d'ailleurs pour réagir
à ce que seront vos réactions merci à
selmaali saraheline qui m'ont aidé à
préparer cette émission prochain
rendez-vous avec des Badoc ça sera la
même place la même heure et bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt